MY LOVE OF MOVIES BEGAN AT
THE LOCAL DRIVE-IN,
WATCHING THE LIKES OF
CLINT EASTWOOD AND GODZILLA.
OUR NOMINEES FOR
BEST SUPPORTING ACTRESS -
ALSO FELL IN LOVE WITH
MOVIES AT AN EARLY AGE.
FOR YUH-JUNG YOUN IT WAS
THROUGH THE WORK OF
ACTRESSES LIKE MAGGIE SMITH
AND DIRECTORS ROBERT ALTMAN
AND MIKE LEIGH.
FOR AMANDA SEYFRIED IT WAS THE
FILM VERSION OF
"ROMEO AND JULIET,"
THE LEO VERSION.
AMANDA. ME, TOO.
MARIA BAKALOVA IT WAS ALL ABOUT
MARILYN MONROE.
SHE'D WRITE OUT,
MARILYN'S QUOTE
"I'M GOING TO BE A GREAT
MOVIE STAR SOME DAY."
MARIA, WELCOME.
AS A YOUNG GIRL OLIVIA COLMAN'S
FAMILY WOULD GATHER AT CHRISTMAS
TIME, GET SOME POPCORN AND WATCH
"THE SOUND OF MUSIC" AND
"CHITTY CHITTY BANG BANG."
AND FOR THE GREAT GLENN CLOSE
SHE WAS ENTRANCED BY CLASSIC DISNEY
MOVIES LIKE "SNOW WHITE,"
AND "OLD YELLER."
AND APPARENTLY IT PAID OFF
SHE ENDED UP BEING CAST AS
CRUELLA DE VIL.
THESE ARE THE NOMINEES
FOR THE BEST SUPPORTING ACTRESS
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO-
YUH-JUNG YOUN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
MR. BRAD PITT, FINALLY.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
WHERE WERE YOU
WHEN WE WERE FILMING?
IT'S AN HONOR TO MEET YOU.
AS YOU KNOW, I'M FROM KOREA.
AND ACTUALLY MY NAME, IS
YUH-JUNG YOUN.
AND MOST EUROPEAN PEOPLE
CALL ME YUH-YOUN
-- AND SOME OF THEM CALL ME --
YUH-JUNG
BUT TONIGHT,
YOU ARE ALL FORGIVEN.
AND USUALLY WHEN I'M LIVING IN
THE OTHER PART OF THE WORLD, I
JUST WATCH THE TELEVISION.
IT'S OSCAR, AN EVENT ON THE
TELEVISION, JUST WATCHING, LIKE
A TELEVISION PROGRAM FOR US.
BUT ME BEING HERE, BY MYSELF,
THIS, I CANNOT BELIEVE I'M HERE.
OKAY.
LET ME PULL MYSELF TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR THE TREMENDOUS,
THANKS TO THE ACADEMY MEMBERS
WHO VOTE FOR ME.
AND THAT'S THE SPEECH,
THEY USUALLY SAY, OKAY, THANK YOU FOR
THE -- WONDERFUL MINARI FAMILY.
STEVEN, ISAAC, YERI, AND NOEL, ALAN
WE BECAME A FAMILY.
AND MOST OF ALL, ABOVE ALL,
LEE ISAAC CHUNG
WITHOUT HIM, I COULDN'T BE HERE
TONIGHT.
HE WAS OUR CAPTAIN AND MY
DIRECTOR.
SO THANKS TO YOU.
TREMENDOUS THANKS TO YOU.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK --
I DON'T BELIEVE IN COMPETITION.
HOW CAN I WIN OVER GLENN CLOSE?
I'VE BEENWATCHING HER,
SO MANY PERFORMANCES.
SO THIS IS JUST -- ALL THE
NOMINEES, FIVE NOMINEES.
WE WERE THE WINNER FOR THE
DIFFERENT MOVIE, WE PLAY THE
DIFFERENT ROLE.
SO WE CANNOT COMPETE EACH OTHER.
TONIGHT, I HAVE JUST A LITTLE
BIT LUCK, I THINK.
I'M LUCKIER THAN YOU.
AND ALSO, MAYBE IS AMERICAN
HOSPITALITY FOR THE KOREAN
ACTOR?
I'M NOT SURE.
BUT ANYWAY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK TO MY TWO
BOYS.
WHO MADE ME GO OUT AND WORK.
SO -- THIS IS THE RESULT.
BECAUSE MOMMY WORKED SO HARD.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO DEDICATE
THIS AWARD FOR MY FIRST
DIRECTOR. KIM KI-YOUNG
WHO WAS VERY GENIUS DIRECTOR, I
MADE THE MOVIE TOGETHER WITH
HIM, FIRST MOVIE.
I THINK HE WOULD BE VERY HAPPY
IF HE WAS STILL ALIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TREMENDOUS THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THANK YOU.